can you be choked by a ghost would force
lightning short out your robo arms how
powerful is darth vader really
young anakin skywalker was a force
sensitive prodigy long before he was
discovered by qui-gon jinn on tatooine
born to a single mother with seemingly
no father anakin grew up fast as a slave
serving watto a local junk dealer
young annie was instinctively good with
machines even building his own protocol
droid known as c-3bo he is also known
locally as the only human who can
podrace without dying it's clear that
his connection to the force the
life-giving energy that surrounds all
living things in star wars and the
supposed explanation of anakin's
immaculate conception is stronger than
just about anyone's in fact anakin's
midi-chlorian count surpassed that of
even yoda despite this the boy lacked
the proper training when qui-gon
discovered anakin he vowed to train him
recognizing the boy to be the
fulfillment of an ancient prophecy that
foretold a jedi who would bring balance
to the force anakin is also a natural
star pilot he is capable of turning even
disastrous crash landings into military
victories although anakin started out
incredibly skilled it's worth noting
that he struggled to use his exceptional
abilities until he began proper training
for 10 years obi-wan kenobi trained
anakin skywalker in the ways of the jedi
teaching him invaluable lessons of
balance and lightsaber technique due to
obi-wan's training and constant support
the young skywalker grew incredibly
skilled with the force willing to
perform life-endangering feats if it
meant bringing villains to justice
anakin exemplified this attitude in
attack of the clones when he jumped out
of a speeder on coruscant only to land
on a bounty hunter's speeder without
coming to any real harm anakin was so in
tune with the force that he could sense
danger from miles away and even between
planets because of these feats anakin
quickly became one of the most notable
jedi in the entire order during the
clone wars anakin was promoted to a jedi
knight and given his own apprentice
ahsoka tano anakin's own stubbornness
and quick to action strategies were
quickly inherited by his padawan who
only grew more powerful thanks to
anakin's teaching for years anakin
fought alongside his master his
apprentice and the clones against the
separatists and their droid armies
dueling with the most dangerous
criminals in the galaxy anakin won
battles against sith lord count dooku
darth maul and general grievous saving
countless lives in the process anakin
would even save his master from harm's
way a number of times you owe me one and
not for saving your skin for the tenth
time
ninth time
that business on caton ammonia doesn't
doesn't count
years went by and anakin skywalker only
became a better jedi though there were
moments of darkness that he would
experience throughout the clone wars
anakin ultimately served the jedi well
his potential and ability were only
highlighted further with each new battle
and every challenge that awaited him
perhaps one of anakin's strongest suits
was his skill with a lightsaber he
preferred the fifth form of lightsaber
technique which emphasizes strong
counter-attacks with the goal of saber
to savor combat while it took him years
to view the weapon as his lifeline
anakin's swordmanship and form were
excellent as a padawan he even took on
count dooku single-handedly though he
lost a hand in the duel in his final
encounter with dooku and revenge of the
sith anakin overpowered the sith lord
before supreme chancellor palpatine
talked him into killing the villain to
progress the jedi knights fall to the
dark side this premeditated murder
strengthened anakin's connection to the
dark side so that by the time he
defected from the jedi he was immensely
more powerful than most sith apprentices
throughout his time as a jedi anakin
skywalker continually felt the need to
prove himself whether it was his own
personal insecurities about his role as
the chosen one or his desire to be the
strongest jedi in history he always
believed he could be better
unfortunately anakin's lust for power
only took him down darker paths and in
moments such as his slaughter of tuscan
raiders after his mother's death and his
murder of count dooku he tasted what
that power could bring at one point
during the clone wars he even saw a
vision of his eventual fate a vision he
would tragically forget it was these
small steps towards darkness that would
prepare anakin for his role as darth
vader unlike emotionally balanced jedi
such as obi-wan yoda or even ahsoka
anakin was prone to fits of anger and
rage this was seen a few times when
anakin used dark side powers such as the
force choke with ease long before he
actually defected to the sith
unfortunately it also left him open to
weakness as he was slowly seduced by
palpatine and his empty promises
although obi-wan and ahsoka anchored
anakin to the light side of the force
even they weren't strong enough to keep
him there forever eventually the young
skywalker left alone let fear overtake
his best judgment
anakin skywalker spent so much time
training his body for battle that he
rarely spent time training his mind this
weakness would prove devastating as he
left his mind open to attack from
thoughts of fear and failure it was for
this reason his prophetic dreams of his
wife padme dying in childbirth led him
to the path of the dark side even among
jedi prophetic dreams were a rare gift
further illustrating how strong anakin's
connection to the force truly was
however they crippled him with fear and
serious doubts about his allegiance i'm
not the jedi i should be
i want
more
and i know i shouldn't palpatine preyed
on these fears ultimately convincing
anakin to betray the jedi order and join
him as darth vader ashamed of his
choices and manipulated into anger at
those closest to him anakin attacked his
former allies and slaughtered all the
remaining jedi at the jedi temple
overpowering many jedi masters including
the high ranking council member mace
windu proved how strong in the force the
young skywalker truly was and his new
dark side abilities dialed his strength
up to 11. killing younglings padawans
and even council members with ease was
just the rush of power anakin needed to
become darth vader of course this was
only made possible once palpatine
harnessed anakin's fear and rage into
something that the new sith lord's own
wife would soon not recognize breaking
her heart and ultimately killing her
with each jedi life he took darth vader
grew stronger completely divorcing his
former morality from his current actions
anakin skywalker severed his
consciousness in a way very few ever
could thus when anakin met obi-wan on
the volcanic battlefield of mustafar
their skills were equally matched
obi-wan represented anakin's last tether
to the light while anakin represented
the sith fully embracing the dark side
had vader not lost this battle he might
have grown to become an even more
powerful sith lord and possibly the most
powerful sith of all but ultimately
anakin's own unchecked anger was his
undoing with severed limbs and burning
flesh acting as the harsh consequences
of his own
anakin skywalker was weak
i destroyed him however revenge is a
powerful motivator it was this that
drove vader to hold on to his life and
eventually hunt down obi-wan and obi-wan
kenobi and ahsoka in star wars rebels
this rage that vader felt towards his
former master even gave him the strength
to stop an entire spacecraft mid-takeoff
throwing it back to the ground and
ripping it apart in search of the jedi
in his second duel with kenobi vader
almost won but rather than finish off
his former master his own arrogance got
in the way reminding obi-wan that he
chose his life as a sith years later in
a new hope vader would finally kill
kenobi in battle however obi-wan only
allowed this because he thought that it
might help luke defeat vader and the
empire
throughout the star wars canon darth
vader has done some incredible things
with the force in the comics he destroys
a dam that floods an entire city killing
millions in star wars rebels he
impossibly survives the destruction of a
sith temple yet sometimes vader seems
pretty selective with his power for
example he doesn't stop the millennium
falcon from leaving hoth in the empire
strikes back nor does he stop leia's
ship in rogue one when the rebels escape
with the death star plans for many these
signs of mercy prove to be major plot
holes in established canon especially
given his apparent power boost in
obi-wan kenobi the truth is to tap into
the power of the dark side one must give
in completely to their emotions and in
vader's case that emotion is often some
sort of anger or rage while he can still
use basic force abilities regardless
thanks to his prior training he needs an
intense amount of rage to perform the
more incredible feats he's known for in
ob1 kenobi vader's hatred for his former
master allows him to stop the spacecraft
from taking off but once that burst of
rage is over his power gauge essentially
resets in the empire strikes back in
rogue one vader simply didn't have that
same desire for revenge to pull from
making his burst of power in obi-wan
kenobi both exciting and unique
although darth vader was further
enhanced by his new robotic limbs and
the suit that controlled it all it
wasn't always what it was cracked up to
be the suit gave vader enhanced physical
strength and a healthy amount of stamina
things anakin skywalker's broken body
could not survive without left alone he
would have eventually died but with his
new enhancements vader could focus on
his connection to the dark side rather
than forcing himself to keep breathing
however being more machine than man came
with its own downsides and challenges as
well though vader's connection to the
dark side was still strong his robotic
limbs left him with some serious power
disadvantages while he could rebuild
himself if need be he was forced to
retrain himself to fight without being
able to feel his limbs most importantly
darth vader would never be able to learn
the sith lightning powers that palpatine
used to kill mace windu in fact the
lightning itself would fry vader's
cybernetics and would eventually be the
cause of his death at the end of return
of the jedi this weakness severely
limited the powers vader could
eventually possess as well as his
ability to overthrow the emperor this is
why he would ask both his former
apprentice ahsoka tano and his own son
luke skywalker to join him in ruling the
galaxy he couldn't do it alone we need
not be adversaries the emperor will show
you mercy if you tell me where the
remaining jedi can be found
the discovery that he has a son would
turn out to be vader's greatest weakness
and his source of redemption after
learning about luke all bets were off
for vader who quickly sought out the boy
to use against the emperor between
episode 4 and episode 5 vader would hunt
for the young skywalker and almost
capture him though the emotional
connection he'd feel toward his son
would prevent him from killing the boy
in battle vader even crashed his tie
fighter rather than risk killing luke in
the vader down crossover of course he'd
have no problem cutting off his son's
hand in the empire strikes back though
it's worth noting he did allow luke to
escape after their battle it's vader's
children who reintroduced him to the
light side of the force allowing him to
rectify his mistakes over the past 20
something years and finally usurp the
emperor though vader fought the light he
eventually embraced it after seeing luke
tormented by his evil master the love
that vader had for his children and for
padme overpowered all his anger and rage
giving him the final burst of strength
he needed to toss palpatine down to his
demise although this self-sacrificing
act was ultimately what killed him
anakin skywalker reclaimed his role as
the chosen one and finally brought
balance to the force a feat that he
could only accomplish with luke's help
though anakin skywalker only returned to
the light side of the force in his final
moments this selfless act proved enough
for him to appear as a force ghost at
the end of the return of the jedi while
not much is known about anakin's time as
a force ghost we do know that he would
eventually come to rey's aid alongside
many other jedi in the rise of skywalker
to finally put an end to the threat of
emperor palpatine once and for all
without the strength of the chosen one
by her side it might have been
impossible for her and anakin's grandson
ben solo to defeat the sith lord
according to obi-wan becoming a force
ghost makes one even more powerful than
they were in life in the last jedi
yoda's force spirit is seen using a form
of force lightning while kenobi's force
ghost often spoke to luke before he was
even ready to see him while it's quite
possible deceased jedi are capable of a
wide array of abilities we have yet to
see anakin's force ghost beyond the
final moments of return of the jedi
however anakin could have more power now
than viewers could even imagine